[Música]
y vamos con nuestra revista de prensa
aquí en directo América de Francia 24 y
con eso Un saludo para usted de Rosa
Pérez Mateo Gracias y bueno hoy tenemos
todo un tema dedicado a México Así es
Buenos días Ángela vamos a ver este
reportaje que hace el país que se llama
de un lado y del otro Así se vive la
desigualdad en México usted nos ha
preparado los apartes más importantes y
el análisis que nos tiene exactamente
empezamos a por la introducción a este
análisis hay que es bastante descriptiva
dice México es y realmente desigual en
Solo dos países del mundo el 1% más rico
de la población concentra más ingresos
que en México estos países son
mozambique y República centroafricana
entonces lo que hace el país es un
análisis sobre cómo se expresa esta
desigualdad de un barrio a otro y es que
si bien la concentración de la riqueza
suele ser gradual en una ciudad es decir
un barrio Ultra rico no está normalmente
al lado de un barrio muy empobrecido hay
algunos lugares particularmente el 0,2%
del territorio mexicano en que está
desigualdad sí que está separada
simplemente por una frontera que
delimita un barrio con el otro
particularmente han analizado 45.000
vecindarios donde se encuentran las
desigualdades más grandes de México dice
el país lugares en los que el vecindario
de un lado es abismalmente diferente del
que tiene del otro lado el resultado es
una radiografía centrada como decíamos
en el 0,2% del territorio mexicano Este
es un texto recordemos que está firmado
por vivir Ríos
Bueno cómo se expresa esta desigualdad
tan abismal y que vale la pena decirlo
Rosa sucede en varias ciudades
latinoamericanas Bogotá por ejemplo ese
es un caso no exactamente hay un poco el
patrón es esta concentración geográfica
de la riqueza y del poder que va
asociado a esta riqueza nos da el
siguiente dato este texto y es que la
clase alta el 10% más rico del país
habita en un territorio que representa
el 0,07% del territorio nacional y que
desde ahí controlan el 47% de la riqueza
del país y dice este texto en México los
ricos viven en espacios separados
cerrados aislados su México es un gueto
protegido por seguridad privada donde
sus niños se conocen en las mismas
escuelas privadas y sus ancianos son
velados en las mismas funerarias ahora
biri Ríos también en el texto nos señala
algunas de las consecuencias más duras
de esta segregación no exactamente y la
principal implicación es el
desconocimiento acerca de cómo viven
unos y otros no
a pesar de que México es uno de los
países más desigualos más desiguales del
mundo las personas raramente
experimentan esta desigualdad por un
lado los ricos no saben cómo viven las
personas en empobrecidas explica Ramón
leucona profesor de la Universidad de
Anáhuac de México que por eso algunas
escuelas de los barrios más adinerados
organizan excursiones a los barrios más
empobrecidos por otro lado la clase
trabajadora sí que visita los barrios de
clase alta para trabajar valgase la
redundancia no pero con frecuencia no
dimensionan la riqueza que observan
según un estudio del colegio de México
si al mexicano promedio se le pregunta
qué ingresos ganan los ricos su
respuesta sería unos 38.000 pesos es
decir unos 2000 dólares y la realidad es
que ganan hasta 37 veces más y además
son discriminaciones a las que estamos
acostumbrados no súper normalizado todo
este tema en las ciudades Ahora hay un
fenómeno que se repite constantemente
cuando
barrios de los llamados ricos colindan
con los empobrecidos y es esta obsesión
que tienen con la seguridad exactamente
Ángela y para poner algunos no de los
ejemplos de las diferencias materiales
que pueden existir entre barrios que
colindan por ejemplo hay barrios donde
el nivel educativo los barrios ricos por
ejemplo en Ciudad de México es
equiparable al que se presupone que
tendrá México dentro de 123 años
mientras que en los barrios empobrecidos
el nivel era el promedio mexicano hace
10 años o barrios en que en los barrios
ricos el acceso a internet es
equiparable al de Holanda y en los
empobrecidos en el de Haití bien estas
diferencias finalmente no como señala la
periodista con una comparación muy
visual acaban pues haciendo digamos
marcadas por muros no por vallas por
seguridad privada y señala la periodista
los ricos mexicanos viven como la muñeca
más chica de una matrioska de estas muñe
rusas no en pequeñecidos por su miedo y
rodeados de capas y capas de seguridad
privada para atenuarlos como tú decías
este denominador como un esta paranoia
de la seguridad dice el negocio del
miedo es multimillonario el gasto en
seguridad privada en México representa
el uno punto siete por ciento del pib
siete veces más que el gasto en
seguridad pública Federal para dar
algunos datos cada dos horas y media
alguien compra un auto blindado en
México no por ejemplo lo que acaba
sucediendo no con estas con este enorme
gasto en la seguridad privada es que
francamente tal y como señala este texto
no se acaba
traduciendo en una reducción de la
criminalidad al contrario no señala este
texto citando a neilmex que hace un
trabajo para la universidad de Oklahoma
que a medida que aumenta La Brecha de
ingresos entre vecindarios los delitos
contra la propiedad aumentan en el
barrio más rico porque la desigualdad
genera aislamiento social y desconfianza
lo que incrementa las probabilidades de
que el crimen aumente señala el texto a
la hora de la verdad los gastos
millonarios en seguridad privada no
sirven De nada no hay dinero que alcance
para sustituir al estado y bien Este es
un caso simplemente simplemente entre
situado en Ciudad de México pero en este
texto también podemos encontrar otros
ejemplos en Playa del Carmen o también
en el Estado de México no finalmente
Ángela un poco a la conclusión de este
texto es que no solamente esta
diferencia material no supone pues esto
desigualdades en término de acceso al
consumo sino que también no la
privatización de otros sectores como la
basura tratamiento de aguas riego las
escuelas la poda los hospitales no al
final acaba generando una desigualdad de
oportunidades y de acceso a derechos
básicos Pues es que lo muestran muy
claramente las imágenes no muros de
árboles muros de edificios que separan
los dos barrios ahora para ir cerrando
muéstranos por favor Rosa algunos de los
ejemplos concretos como la frontera
entre los barrios Ciudad de México del
popular Santa Teresa y también Fuentes
del Pedregal pues por ejemplo Ángela
para terminar no en Fuentes del Pedregal
en Ciudad de México un barrio rico Pues
hay un 95% de las viviendas que tienen
cisterna mientras que en Popular de
Santa Teresa solo el 50% en el Fuentes
del Pedregal el barrio rico hay tantos
ocupantes por vivienda como en Canadá
mientras que en el Popular de Santa
Teresa este número sería equiparable a
Kenia no en Playa del Carmen por ejemplo
en playa Card viviendas con Netflix son
un 95%, mientras que en las torres un 0%
y así muchísimos ejemplos que podemos
encontrar en este texto y muchísimos
otros testimonios Pues gracias a la
periodista que hizo a Viri Ríos Pues por
hacernos esta radiografía y usted
también por presentarnos la rosa Gracias
a ti